for average person computer is some sort
of machine which allows them to use
certain applications at the same time
mathematically you can define a computer
as a concrete mathematical model and
study its properties you can study which
computational problems can be solved
fast which problems cannot be solved
fast this involves using quite deep
mathematical techniques I grew up in
this town college shell chironji in
India in both my and my wife's family
everybody is a doctor except for me and
my wife and in fact in the natural
course of events I would have ended up
being a doctor but there was some lucky
coincidences I ended up being the
mathematician it's a bit difficult for
me to say what I do when I'm not doing
math because that's what I'm doing most
of the time but I enjoy a lot playing
with my son nev for me work and
enjoyment or work and relaxing these are
all really the same
it might come as a surprise to you that
we are so interested in knowing that
certain computational problems cannot be
solved in particular cannot be solved
fast we ought to investigate both the
power as well as limitations of our
methods from practical point of view
it's often useful that certain
computational tasks cannot be performed
for example I'm sure you would be happy
to know that a hacker cannot break into
your bank account and steal all your
money one of the important contributions
has been proposing the unique games
conjecture and then developing research
around this conjecture I was vacationing
in India visiting family this small idea
came to me that if I use this unique
games conjecture as a starting point of
my field of research it would really
make the whole field easier and very
consistent
I will describe the kind of games that I
like to play by giving a toy example so
this is really a puzzle constructed by
my collaborator Donna moshkovich on the
left-hand side you have categories such
as animals verbs transportations and so
on and on the right hand side you have a
column of boxes and you want to fill up
these boxes with letters so you have to
pick up these words for different
categories on the left hand side so that
they are consistent with the letters
that you put on the right hand side so
it's a puzzle results of this kind if
they are very large in size computers
cannot solve these puzzles fast or
efficiently so that's really the P
naught equals NP conjecture if the
conjecture is true then it would be
really nice it's as if all the pieces of
a big puzzle they are kind of fitting
together very nicely I knew that as of
now nominated me for the prize this year
it wasn't clear to me what a huge honor
this was until I actually received a
call from president of the International
math union receiving the prize does
place additional responsibility on the
recipient but maybe all these additional
responsibilities are for the better